What is the biggest worry that people normally
cite and say, this is scary. We need
to do something about this. This is a
moral imperative. What is, what is behind that?
>> Aside from the movie Gattaca, which I think is
behind a lot of it. It's a very scary movie.
>> It is.
>> I don't know if you've seen it
lately. GINA was conceived of and passed because people,
people are very concerned that opportunities will be forestalled,
based on a possibility, of some genetic issue that could
befall them later on in life. That they're being you
know, pre-judged pre-penalized. Based on something that might not happen.
>> So GINA, or the Genetic Information Nondiscrimination Act.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Was passed in 1995 and
what did it do? What?
>> GINA was actually signed into law in 2008 it was a very long process.
So it, the fight to create GINA first began in 1995. You
know, bunch of the bills that eventually
became GINA started circulating through the government
back in 95 and probably being talked of even earlier. GINA's general goal is
to prevent discrimination by employers with 15 or more employees or by
insurers. Based on an individual's genetic information, or family medical
history. So they included family medical history, in part. Because, you know?
Not everyone has had their genomes sequenced. But the idea is.
There are a lot of. This breaks down
into a lot of different provisions, of course,
a lot of different individual granular protections that
an insurer cannot raise premiums based on the
fact that, say, my aunt had breast cancer. I may or may not carry one of
the BRCA gene variants that would increase my
likely risk of receiving breast cancer. I cannot
be charged under GINA a higher premium for that. Likewise, your
insurer or your employer cannot require that you undergo any type of genetic
testing to asses your risk for developing any condition. Your, it permits
of course in a health care provider to recommend genetic testing for various
purposes, but even then an insurer or an employer
can only collect the bare minimum of information that they
need to have for coverage decisions, basically they cannot collect and store
Additional information regarding your genetic makeup, predispositions.
>> Do you feel the concern about genetic discrimination is valid?
>> Absolutely, I
mean, you can all too easily imagine an employer You know
saying, you know, let's not say breast cancer, let's say someone has a you know
they've had their genome they've had their genome coded, and they show a
likelihood. It shows that you know
they will almost certainly develop Huntington's, say
and an employer who wants to make a long term investment in an employee, if they
have access to that information, they're allowed to
make decisions based on it. Might say, you
know we'd really rather have someone who will
have a longer working life with us. Likewise
an insurer. I mean, insurers make their money.
Based on having the maximum number of basically healthy
people, paying into the insurance pool. Which then
>> Right.
>> Goes to pay for
>> Sure.
>> The less healthy people. it is in the insurer's best interest to keep as
many people who are going to develop
serious conditions out of that pool as possible.
>> Mm-hm. So, yeah. I think that's a completely
rational concern that people have that led to GINA.
I think it's one of the few occasions when,
as you said, they've sort of, got out ahead
of the possibility of experiencing this type of discrimination.